what advice do you have - first time
second time filmmakers on seeking a
distribution deal and then actually
committing to it this is a tough
question for me because every time you
make a deal you learn about new deals
I'll give you an illustration when I
made my first movie we didn't have
people knocking on her door to
distribute my movie we had sales reps I
never even knew what that was but
there's a lot of companies in LA in
Hollywood that are sales rep they rep
and they would take your movie to
Netflix and they would take your movie
to Fox and they would make deals and I
totally believe in that scenario never
even occurred to me you know that my
next movie would be good enough for
someone to go we want to distribute it
of course there's no money exchanged you
know you have to wait get the movie
distributed and then eventually make
your money back but if you're lucky
enough to hypothetically wake up in the
morning and Sundance and somebody buys
your movie to distribute it they might
say we'll give you X dollars not to
mention the fact that after advertising
dollars are spent we'll give you 50
cents on the dollar you know whatever it
might be I did not have that luxury but
I did have the luxury this time of
getting a reputable distribution company
and taking it up a notch
so each time you I learn more but
distribution and I'm saying this
redundant ly because I said it before is
an ever-changing medium and you know I'm
learning right as we speak that you know
filmmakers are expected to do things
that have then do with filmmaking and
that is if you really want to succeed
with your movie social media has to be
played you have to do self marketing
yourself you got to do interviews like
this and I'm really grateful but you
know I'm not a social media guy you know
and but you have to learn how to do that
and it's fascinating to me because I
have a number I don't know on my
facebook I got no
people that are filmmakers so everyone
so I see a filmmaker promoting their
movie and you know I'm empathetic
because it requires just an inordinate
amount of collective collaboration with
the distributor to succeed because
they're making distributor picked up my
movies making it puts out four movies a
month that's 48 movies that's a lot of
movies for a small company and one of
the ones I passed on did 30 or 40 movies
of mine and they're into the volume
aspect so I felt that the one that I
picked was more desirable because they
would give it more energy and more time
and I don't have a regret for that but
here again I'm speaking from first-time
experience yeah I met a gentleman just
last week who's doing our social media
and he's also a director a smart guy
young guy and you know he I think if I
was able to tell him what I learned now
on his first movie he would have done
something differently and it's not like
he made a horrific mistake but he
ultimately took his movie off the market
you know and that is there are other
ways to do it
no different than the woman he told me
that on my new film you know my last
movie wasn't ever exploited on social
media and the content matter itself
should have been an easy pitch but we
didn't do it so is it a missed
opportunity not really because the the
source material is timeless it's
happening every day and it still
continues to happen but you know this
movie that I just finished comes out
basically a week before Valentine's
dates it's no accident it's a romantic
comedy I like that idea you know it
helps take the movie to a noticeable
level otherwise you're just gonna get in
the mush yeah there's a great story in
the trades about Netflix buying movies
at Sundance last year not this year last
year
and it's written by empathetic
filmmakers that said that here's a movie
that is everybody knows the title
everybody would like to see it but it
was on Netflix for one week on the first
page and then it just disappeared so you
have to really know a lot about the
movie properly spell it and source it
and that it's like me I went last night
on Amazon to try to see if my movie was
up for sale because it just came out and
it required me to go through some closed
doors in order to get there I'm talking
about searching for it because when I
typed in the name it didn't pop right
out and there's a whole nother subject
you know naming your movie I think
distributors would prefer you name your
movie ABCD you know because it's it's
closer to the beginning of the alphabet
perhaps not anymore because everybody
now is searching for their films and you
just type it in but analytics play a
role now you know you go on to Netflix
are going to Amazon and you you're
trending with romantic comedies they'll
suggest my movie hopefully so that is
you know a plus to them we were making
money and a plus to the distributor
who's making money but all that stuff
never existed I mean the formats of
Netflix and Amazon have changed three
times in the last month meaning how like
right now when you click on a movie on
Amazon a trailer pops up in Netflix too
you know the trailer for anything you're
watching a TV show or whatever while
you're still searching it's playing the
commercial that's all new and innovative
technology and and it helps the
filmmaker but to me what's really
critical is is that if you know about a
filmmaker like me talking about what I
experienced you try to avoid that with
your own experience
so maybe my movie would be called you
know come and eat the food so it's C
rather than an M or maybe it doesn't
matter anymore
you